earlier we talked about teenagers to
engaged in the online world that is not
the case for two Scottish brothers who
have been pursuing some very imaginative
real-life adventures 500 of them to be
exact and one of them is gaining
attention around the world for Olli and
Harry Ferguson life is an adventure for
the past four years the brothers have
been working to complete a list of 500
challenges and experiences the idea came
about actually from the boys the boys
and we just asked the one day if they
could come up with some cool things for
us to go and do as a family and they
they come up with some hilarious ideas
initially like going on a mission to
Mars and intergalactic sausage day and
all sorts of strange kids requests and
from there Vicky and I built the list
200 findings that we wanted to go and
try they're all cataloged on the
brothers Facebook page so far they have
built an igloo explored the wilderness
sent their Lego men into the depths of
the ocean and into outer space
well we attached a GoPro log to it like
a magnet but perhaps their biggest
adventure is playing out right now on
the high seas last year Ollie and Harry
launched a toy pirate ship from the
Scottish coast the boat aptly named
adventure sailed across the North Sea to
Scandinavia it then hitched a ride on a
Norwegian boat and was launched again
this time off the coast of West Africa
adventure traveled all the way across
the Atlantic Ocean and is currently in
the Caribbean Sea about a hundred and
fifty miles from Venezuela the adventure
is equipped with a tracking device
allowing the brothers to follow every
step of the voyage but the battery on
the tracking device is starting to
dwindle so Harry and Ollie hope a
passing ship spots their boat and is
able to recharge its battery allowing
the adventure to continue I would get to
go to school because that would be
halfway around the world on the beaches
there China about that a B PB and all
boats point bulletin it's amazing it's
still afloat and can I say I would love
to send my lego man into space with a
GoPro what great parents amazing cool
stuff